uh conjecture thank you very much and i
thank the organizers in particular
giorgio for this nice invitation
so yeah as luke said already i will talk
about strassen's conjecture and enrique
already gave a very nice introduction
from the metrics
multiplication point of view so i will
avoid doing that but i will just start
by
writing the statement of this conjecture
mainly because i want to fix the
notation so
yeah i should also say first of all that
this is joint
work in progress with jared muchinski
okay let me start by
writing down the statement of
strassense conjecture
and then gonna write it for by linear
map so for three-way tensors and this is
the case i'm going to talk about enrico
instead talked about
symmetric tensors and polynomials
okay let's take three vector spaces
a b
and c
and then we take
direct sum decomposition a1 plus
a2
b1
plus b2
c1 plus c2
and then what i want to do is to take a
tensor
pj in
aj tensor bj
tensor cj
for j equal one and two
so i'm taking two tensors that live in
two skew spaces and i'm gonna ask
whether the rank of the sum of these two
tensors seen in the big space is equal
to the sum of the ranks so that's
strassen's conjecture straw sensativity
conjecture so
this is what we would like to prove or
disprove
that the rank of p1 plus p2
is equal to the rank of p1 plus
the rank of v2
okay so let me first of all
write down
what we know already what we knew
already about so some positive answer to
this question
which is due to
jarek and jm in a paper by from 2013
so they proved well that paper was not
about strassen's conjecture but on their
way they prove those some
cases where strassen's conjecture is
true for the rank of three-way tensor so
they prove that whenever
the rank of p1 the first of my two
elements is at most equal to the maximum
between the three
dimensions of the space involved
a1 b1 c1 and by this number i just mean
a1 is the dimension of
capital a1 and so on
so whenever the rank of p1 is at most
previous number then
let me just give a symbol let's call it
sac strassen additivity conjecture
and
under this hypothesis they can prove
that sac holds
and this has very nice consequences that
i will tell about but let me first just
briefly sketch the proof of this
of this lemma or proposition
so
it's it's really
it's really short we can first of all
assume that this tensor p1 is concise
and what does it mean
well it basically means that if i take
the image
of
a1 star
inside b1 tensor c1
this is injective this is not the image
but the map is injective sorry
and the same for the other
two maps that i can take by
swapping the roles of the three spaces
involved so this i can always do i can
always assume that p1 is coincides and
then in this particular case i
then i want that the rank of p1 is
exactly equal to the maximum
of the three dimensions
i can also well order the three
dimensions this is also without loss of
generality i can also assume that this
is exactly a1 which is bigger or equal
than b1 and then c1
yeah
so okay so these are my assumptions to
simplify the problem to simplify the
proof
so what do i do well then i take p
the sum of my two tensors now p1 lives
in such a space and p2 is any other
tensor living in a skew space
i take the sum of the two of them and
then i write
them
with a minimal i write a minimal
presentation as a sum of
rank one tensors a alpha i
tensor beta i tensor gamma i
from one to r where r is the rank of the
sum of some number which is
corresponding to the rank of the sum and
then i just basically take
well i just basically check what happens
if i take the projection
from the big space to the space where p2
sorry where p1 lives
where p2 let me write it it's better at
least i don't mistake the
indexes so i'll just
take now
i just take the projection from the big
space to
a2 x b2
tensor c2
and what happens well under these
assumptions i can immediately see that
p1
lives in the kernel this this the space
where p1 leaves is in the kernel of this
projection so
maybe
this is contained in the kernel
and in particular p1 is inside here so
this means that
the image of p1
is zero
and then what what happens to p2 well a2
tensor these are obvious things
trivialities this so if i take the
projection and restrict it to this space
then this is an isomorphism
so this is an iso so this means that
the projection of p2 is itself
and so if i put this information
together then i get that the projection
of p is p2
that's what i'm doing i'm just
projecting to one of the two
tensors so this means that projection of
p
is equal to p2
but also
i can also write it
like
in this way as a sum of projections of
rank one things
so
since by conciseness i can assume
without loss of generality that the
first a1 of the alphas
are for they form a basis for a1 then
then i can just write this like
summation i from a1 plus 1
to r
projection of alpha i tensor beta i
tensor gamma i
so
this just by writing it in this two ways
then i can just conclude because this
immediately will tell me that the rank
of
p2 which is this projection is at most r
minus a1 and i'm done because a1 is
really the rank of b1 so this is at most
r minus
a1
and this is
my assumption the rank of a1 so so i'm
done in this case thrust and
transactions is true
so there are
very nice but also easy consequences
immediate consequences of this lemma
so
if i just look at this assumption what i
can immediately say is that
ruler
is that if a1
is bigger or equal than the product of
b1 and c1
for instance
then then
s a c
holds
because again i can assume that such a
tensor leaving in a space with these
dimensions is coincides so in particular
this means that i can take a1 being
equal to the product of b1 and c1 and
then and then and this is satisfied so
so i get that all these
all these cases satisfy strategies
conjecture
another corollary
maybe a corollary of the corollary is
that whenever c1
is one
i'm assuming that they are ordered by
the big from the bigger to the smaller
so a1 is bigger or equal than b1 bigger
or equal than c1 so if i take the
smallest to be exactly one well what do
i get here well i just get the
trivialities also in this case
uh
s a c
holes
so these are easy consequences
there is another very interesting
corollary that one obtained obtains by
applying this lemma to a particular case
which is
also
also this is in
from the same paper by eric and lansberg
and jm
so if i take p1
to be
a tensor in this space
now i'm using the c notation because
it's convenient because i need
some relation among the dimensions so i
take
c
b one so a
complex space of dimension b one five
plus one tensor c
to the b one tensor c two
well if p1 is a tensor belonging to this
phase then also in this case structs and
conjectures
it's true no matter what the second
tensor i want to take is it's your space
holds
but this is not just as easy as
previously because here we need to know
what the rank
of such a sensor is
but the ramp well this is this is a
pencil of mattresses i have dimension 2
here so i can think of this element like
a pencil of matrices
of size b1 plus 1
by b1 so i can think of it this element
and i can write it like
this
s s s
and then t
so i'm i'm using the so the the way to
compute this rank
the rank of such an element it was
it turns out to be b1 plus one and this
was computed by
now i'm sure that i will mispronounce
all these names
burgesser klausen and chakralahi
just
in 97 1997 they proved by using the
kronecker normal form of of a pencil of
matrices of this form they proved that
the rank is b1
and so we are done because again the
rank of this tensor is equal to the
maximal dimension so by that lemma
we are done
so this is also another
nice example
no matter what the other vector the
other tensor is we get that additivity
holds for for the rank
so
but now let's let's discuss our our
results so with yarek we managed to
generalize this kind of results to prove
that strassen's conjecture hold for a
bigger family of cases
so i will first of all state our theorem
and then i will give a sketch of the
proof and this will be
the first part of my talk and then in
the second part also depending on how
much time i have
i will talk about the border run version
of strats and conjecture for three-way
tensor so i will discuss a little bit
that other case
in the second part of my talk
so
this is our
result
okay so the statement is very easy so if
c1 is equal to so again i'm assuming
that
a1 is going to be one
bit
without loss of generality
so if the smallest dimension is two well
i can say at most two if it was one we
said it already that the conjecture is
true so there is a graph
just by completeness i can just state it
like this if the third dimension is at
most two then i have additivity
so
proof
so i will split the proof in claims so i
will claim
things and then i will show the claims
afterwards
so plain one
um
okay so i claim that
there always exists
a rank one
matrix
let me call it x
in
in the image
of
this map
the one from
a1 star 2.
we want answer c1 so if i see my tensor
as such a map then i claim that
if i take the image of a1 star inside
this space of mattresses i would always
find a rank one matrix
inside there
under the assumption that this is at
most true
and
claim so assuming that this is true
this is reason really easy we'll see
later
then claim two is that there exists a
minimal
presentation
uh of
b
that is the sum of p1 and v2
has in q in rank 1 tensors
q1 qr
says that
one of them let's say the first one
belongs to the first space belongs to
the space where p1 leaves a1 tends to be
one tensor c1 so such that
q1
we are for an element in
a1
tensor
around one matrix
is
a1
and then assuming that this is also true
assuming both of these statements then
what do i do well three
well now i basically just
prove my statement by contradiction by
just proving that if there's a counter
example
to the stress and conjecture so if
additivity doesn't hold in one example
then i can always get rid of this rank
one thing and decrease the dimensions
involved and find another counter
example but i will assume that the
counter example i start with is minimal
so this will be a contradiction this is
the summary of what i'm going to write
in the next two minutes
so
assume
my tensor that i'm studying is
let's call it a counter example
2 sac
so
assuming that the rank
of p
is strictly less than the sum of the
ranks
p1 plus
and also
i'm also assuming that p
is minimal
with respect to this property
its property
and satisfying the same assumption on
the on the dimension we need a minimal
range
he is a middle ranker everything is
limitless
not pp i'm just saying that p i'm
assuming
minimal with respect to this to the
property that it doesn't satisfy
additivity and it is contained in a
space
like that
no not minimal rank it's more was more
or less let's say smallest uh
likes
minimal dimension
of the space it's yeah
okay but frankie's gonna work as well so
whatever you want okay
yeah
okay so uh well then then if i have all
of this then i just take
a prime so i'm gonna show that i get
a smaller so in a small space i'm gonna
get another such counter example p prime
that i will call p prime so v prime i'll
just take it to be
p minus q one so i'm just getting rid of
this rank one
element that lives in the first phase
that i know it exists by the previous
claims so i'm now just taking p1 being
defined by p minus q1 well it is
straightforward to see that
the rank of p1
decreased by 1 with respect to the rank
of p of course i removed around one
thing so
this is exactly rank of p minus one but
then i can also write it as
a sum of an element in a1 times would be
one tensor c1 and an element in the skew
tensor space so p1 prime plus b2
when p2 is the same as before i'm not
touching p2 at all and p1
is p1 prime sorry is
yeah the obvious choice p1 minus q1
and i know that this guy lives in a1
b1 tensor c1
and then yeah and what happens to the
rank of p1 prime that's what they need
to see
well
it may decrease by one but it it may
also not decrease at all but for sure it
is at most rank of p1
minus one i don't know exactly what
happens but for sure this is satisfied
so
well now i just put together these
inequalities with this inequality and i
get that the rank so i get that
that the rank of p prime
is bounded by
it's strictly less than
well
just
and some of the branchs of the tensors
have started with -1 but this is exactly
rank of p1
this is at most sorry rank of p1 prime
plus rank of p2
and so i got a smaller
counter example so this this gives me
so in order to finish the proof i have
to show that the claims
are true so
so to prove
probably on the sum in the very middle
of the board yeah there's a
first negative should be plus
ah yeah sorry yeah
thanks
okay so uh to prove claim one well this
is just a dimension count
because i want to show that if i take
the image of a one star inside here i
want to show that it contains
around one element so what i got what
i'm gonna do well i'm just
well recall
that
b1
is
less or equal than a1 this is my
assumption but also i'm assuming that
a 1
is at most 2 times b 1
and not equal to it i mean
this i didn't assume anywhere but the
point is that 2 is exactly this is c2
this is c1
so i know already that strassen's
conjecture is true when a1 is equal to
the product so i i would not be proving
that now so basically i could have
assumed this from the very beginning so
i'm just taking cases where this is
strictly less because i otherwise
we said we said it already in the
previous in the previous blackboard for
whiteboard so
okay so this this i have this assumption
on the numbers so what do i do with it
well now i just take
v
one to be
the image
i want to study this
this space of mattresses and i want to
find the brown corn element inside here
so what is the obvious thing to do well
i just take the secret
variety inside that space which is the
variety of random matrices and they just
check if they intersect and and they
will
that's just a dimension count so
well
i like to take the projectivization of
this
and this is since i'm assuming
all all of these and i'm also assuming
that p1 is coincides this is just an a1
minus one dimensional projective space
this is a p
a one minus one
which is contained in the
projectivization of b one tensor c one
which is
a
two b one minus one
and now we're gonna take the segregat s
the second embedding of uh
p
one times p
c one second embedding of the
projectilizations of the spaces i'm
considering this also leaves here and
then it has dimension
i need to know the dimensions of these
two spaces and then because i want to
check if they intersect
so this as we mentioned the first one as
you mentioned a1 minus one this is
dimension b1
see this is just a p this is a p b minus
one cross p one so the dimension is b
one
and then and now we are done because
this plus this is bigger than this
and now dimension of
this is b well a1 minus 1 plus b1 that
by assumption i know it's bigger than
the dimension of the ambient space so
i'm done
there there exists there exists around
one thing
inside here and then we are left to
prove claim two
number three before
okay
yeah first of all i don't want to notice
that the rank of p
is bigger or equal than a1 plus e2 that
this is just by coincidence
before the assumptions i'm making to
reduce the problem so this
uh is it clear should i
the rank of p1 is bigger than a1 bigger
equal than one the rank of p2 is bigger
or equal than any dimension involved in
p2 and then of course the wrong i mean
this is this is true so now i want to
prove that if p that there exists a
minimal presentation of p
such that one of these rank one elements
is actually living in in this in the
first place i want some b1 then so c1 so
i just want to use this one
matrix that i just found
so
um
okay
p is
the sum of rank 1 elements r of them and
now let v
inside b
1 tensor c 1
be a vector space of dimension r
which is basically spanned by this rank
one elements so if we contain the image
of a one
in the big space
um let's run it by
round one mattresses
well now i noticed that we just want to
notice that
w which is the image of a
which is the
image of
a star
in the map in yeah inside b tensor c
that this is contained in v
because v is funded by this i know that
p i can write it like this so for sure
if i take the image of a one then i just
stay inside here but this this v
one can show that it's the direct sum of
v1 and v2 w1 w2 sorry defined in this
way
for the for both spaces so and in
particular i know that inside here i
have a rank one
element so
so i can i can
find the basis of v for which
x is one of the elements of the basis so
i'm done
because i want to prove that peak i can
write it as a sum of random things and
one of them is is inside
the first the first space so i'm done
okay so um
yeah this is the end of the proof of our
main result and now i wanted as i
promised i wanted to spend a few words
about um
the borderline version
of strassen's conjecture so basically i
can one can well this has been discussed
already several times during this
workshop one can
replace
so yeah so i just want to ask so if you
know the strategy is it also true that
the only minimal decomposition comes
from the uh from the summit
meaning that you know can you can i get
another minimum decomposition
that mixes things that's what luca was
asking yeah
yeah so the strongest yeah that's the
point i mean i want to say yeah i mean i
cannot exclude that there exists a
different
decomposition that mixes up things
but what i'm using here is that
one of them must be
fixed somehow
that but has it has been observed that
such a thing happens
i mean this is obviously false for
matrices
but otherwise we don't know what yeah
but in order
if you wanted to get a counter example i
think that would be the only way you
found it
to mix things up and then suddenly find
rank one elements which are no longer
only living in one of the two
skill spaces i mean if you slice your
box
then if you just start from p1 and p2
like they are from they are given from
the beginning then all slices they will
only contain elements either
either i mean if this is the shape of a
slice then element would be either here
or here
that's that's what you start with but
now you want to rewrite your box with
somehow
and check if there's some way to to find
a wrong one element that involves
something here and here so it must be
involving something everywhere if it has
to have rank one and that's
of course it doesn't it doesn't happen
when you have yes
x plus right squared yes
yeah
yeah that's that's that's sort of yeah
but it may happen that you have
something that has to say
finally many different positions yes
i see so it's not no so even even when
you can prove the conjecture the
stronger statement is potentially true
but it's not known yes
so uh
you have to add some simple assumptions
unless you had extra hypotheses
because it's false for matrices so you
could just add a one-dimensional vector
space
and it would still be false the smaller
conjunction right but then you know
tensors once you go beyond matrices
no but you can convert you could just
add a dummy extra vector space
and then you could masquerade that you
added a dummy vector space by adding in
yet another cleanser that
you know
so there's you have to have some kind of
extra hypotheses that
make it not obviously false
should i continue okay so
so yeah so i was saying that
one may just naively replace the symbol
rank with the symbol border rank just by
adding an
underscore
and ask whether
this is also true
if the
border wrong version of trust and
conject addictivity is true well no it's
in general it is false and there is a
well-known count
family of counter examples that has been
discussed this morning during the
lecture by jm schoenhage
example or counter example so
the answer is no in general no
there do exist
counter examples
but what i'm gonna do is to give
positive answers to to find examples
where it actually holds
by by using equations for certain
varieties but let me first yeah uh
briefly
come to example so
the well-known one is by sean hager
that it was already
written down on this whiteboard this
morning let me just
uh recall it briefly so in the same
notation that i was using these are the
dimensions of the spaces so we are
taking a1 being equal to the product of
b1 tensor c1 we know already that in
this case
just by writing this we know that the
the wrong version
holds
but this is actually a counter example
for
for the border rank
and
what else a2 equal to one and then b2
equals c2
equal to the product of b1 minus one
minus one then
you want to take a tensor
or rank a1
and the tensor mp2 of board around sorry
b2 i think
and and and then yeah and these are all
counter examples and the first case the
smallest case
yes
this is the counter example in those
dimensions but you're not saying that
every
possible direction no no no no that
there exists a counter example in this
setting
just by thinking a tensor in this no no
no no no
so the first
case
happens when i have these numbers this
is like seven five four are the
dimensions of the big space and this is
the splitting six plus one three plus
two two plus two and the proof well it
has been discussed already the point is
that you want to take a one plus two
points on the segway such that
a1 plus one are independent and then you
want to take curves with initial points
these points that you start with and you
want to take derivatives by taking the
derivatives you get points on the
tangent spaces and by taking 12 second
order derivatives you get you obtain
two such tensors for which the the
border rung of the sum is uh
i think it's actually a one minus one so
it's it's less than
than the sum so this in this way this is
going to be
a family of counter examples but
so there is another
even smaller counter example to
to a strassen's conjecture for
borderland that was
discussed and communicated by jm it was
found by a student of him young queen
one he's in the audience and i'm just
giving you the
numbers just to show you that this is
really smaller
four plus one two plus two
two plus two
so he found a tensor in
c4 tensor c2 1032 of border rank four
and a tensor in c1 1032 tensor c2 of
border round two but the
tens the border rank of the sum is not
six but but five days we proved also
with jarek and then this exam i mean the
proof is basically the same idea as
sean hager example
it's performing the same kind of
arguments and all and also
this belongs to to a family actually of
counter examples in the same way so you
can take
i just wanted to write the smallest
counter examples known but as i said i
want to talk about positive answers
so i want to show examples where this is
actually true
so
uh
okay
so
now i see i i still have 10 minutes so
i'll
at least i give one and then okay so i
will stick with this notation
three plus one three plus one
three plus one are the dimensions
so i want to take
a tensor p1
in
c3 tensor c3 tensor c3 of border rank 5
so i'm taking a tensor
that doesn't live on the fourth second
variety of p2 times p2 times p2 which is
a hypersurface so i take something which
is outside
of this hypersurface and then i take in
the other space well i don't have enough
choices this is a synthetic tensor
system so i just take a gram one tensor
so and i want to show
that the
border rank of the sum of these two
tensors is exactly six
which is the sum and in order to do this
i use
equations for the sigma four for the c
fourth secant variety to the product p
two tensor p two times which is
strassen's degree nine equation
so that i'm going to write down so use
strassen's
equation
for
sigma 4
of p2 and times p2
times v2 in c
in p26
so well actually i'm using what is
called otabiani's
derivation this
so the point is that okay i take a point
p one a tensor p one in in the first so
in c3 tensor c3 tensor c3 i can think of
it as a point on the segment embedding
of the i'm abusing notation this is the
second value of this tree okay so from a
little piece you want to show that the
border rank of the sum is six
but you're going to use equations for
sigma 4.
i i'm starting yeah let me yeah i'll get
there i'm starting from a vector that
doesn't satisfy that equation and then i
get to a vector that
doesn't yeah
okay so um
so
let me slice it so i take a tensioner
and see 3 times 3 times 33 and i slice
it in this way alpha 1
tensor x 1 plus alpha alpha 2
tens or x 2 plus alpha 3
pencil
x 3 where the x i's
leave our matrices
in c3
c3 so this is v one and one
uh these are the slices in alpha one
alpha two alpha three three are a basis
for a one that is a c3 and then i take i
can take the contraction operator
p one
so parentheses i'm going to give the
matrix corresponding to this so you
don't should shouldn't bother too much
about this but this is something that
goes from it's a composition of
um
of the way i write the tensor as
so i basically write p1 as a tensor from
b1 star to a1 tensor c1 and then i
tensor by a1
in
both um sides
i'm tensoring this map by the identity
and then i take a projection into the
wedge product well doesn't matter i mean
this is just a notation environment and
just writing the metrics corresponding
to this
so given by
the block matrix that let's let us call
it m
that depends on x1 x2 x3
matrices like like in this case but i
mean this is just
general you can think of them as
variables so i'm writing this
0 x3
i mean
most of you will recognize for sure this
matrix this is what you write when you
want to write
strassen's degree 9 equation for the
sigma 4
x 2
minus x 1
0
so
i just take this map which is given by a
block matrices and
each block is is is not i mean these are
nine
blocks nine matrices
and then
the lemma that we are going to
i use i put giorgio
0 7
so if
a1
is is equal to 3 and b1 and c1
are bigger yeah i'm sorry now i'm
inverting the pad on i'm inverting the
order yeah i noticed it only now sorry
so if
p1
an elements that lives in this space
with this dimension if p1 belongs to the
sigma r
of the corresponding segreg embedding
then
then the rank of this matrix
so this matrix is bounded above
by r times
a1 minus one
and in particular when all three
spaces have dimension 3 which is our
case i mean p1 is going to be something
inside here then in particular
p1
then in in this case i take r to be
equal to four that's the fundamental i
mean important number in this and i get
that the rank
of this matrix
is eight
just yeah plugging in numbers in this
but that's actually an ethanol leaf and
this is and this is the degree nine
equation for the sigma four
so if i take now a tensor like this in
c3 tensor c3 tends to c3 and i write it
in this way then this the determinant of
this matrix is going to give me the
equation so that's how i check is that
that point lives in the sigma 3 and i'm
starting from a point that doesn't
so now i'm starting so this is just
variables
i mean this is just a formula but then
when i put in the formula my three
matrices then i'm assuming that this
rung has this matrix as full rank nine
and um
this is my assumption but now so i want
to so now this is about p1 but now i
want to prove that p1 plus p2 has rank
6 as rank 6
so
and for proving that i'm going to use
the first part of this lemma that's why
i wrote it just
or
yeah uh
in the following way so that's a very
i would say geometric argument because
now i just take
um
yeah now i'll just write in a convenient
way b1 plus p2
well p1 okay is again
it's alpha i
cancel x i that's what i wrote already
but then i also
add
the fourth element where so i just need
to say what x
oh yeah sorry that i should change
notation because this is now a mattress
in
a four by four matrix so yeah let me
do it properly so now i write
p
as this
where
y i
is a four by four matrix
that is given by
yeah x i a three by three matrix and
then zeros
for i
equal one to three so i'm just adding a
row and a column two to the x side that
i started with and now y4
well
it's
zero
here and only one here
that's zero and zero so this is three
i'm just writing p in a compact way
in order to have something that i can
manipulate in order to use
what is written on this board so
continue
so now my p
is this sensor and i want to show that
the borderline is six so what do i do
well i take
the projection from
a tensor b tensor c so this is c4 tensor
this is the big space it's a four four
four dimensional space i project it
to a1
tensor b tensor c so i'm just
i'm just
contracting the first factor and how do
i do that i send alpha i
to alpha i
for one two three
so i just don't modify that part and i
send
alpha four to the sum alpha one plus
alpha two plus alpha three
so what happens to p when i apply this
projection what is the image what is the
projection of p
inside this space
that now has dimension 3 4 4.
so what happens to p
well um
p prime
that is y applied to p the projection of
p
so this now i've write
in this way
it's a sum alpha
i
tensor and the sum now goes from one to
three now i'm in a c3 space
tensor y
i prime
where
what y i prime is just so the point is
that i have three matrices in this three
by three block
and zeros elsewhere and then i have one
matrix which is zero there and only have
one and if you follow the projection
what happens
to this one it's gonna be this one it
will go to this position for all the
other mattresses so that's just
why
i prime is just y i sorry x i
with one and then zero zero zero
zero zero zero that's what i get so i'm
just replacing zero by one basically so
that's that's my new element
and
i can consider this contraption
operation associated to p prime
so this is something that is described
by a matrix
which is given by this matrix where i
put the y i prime inside here
so
so
what i get is this
y 1 prime y 2 prime y 3 prime so i'm
just taking that and i'm replacing x i
by y i prime so this is that this is it
and then i can manipulate it so i'm
interested in computing the rank of this
matrix because then i want to use this
lemma to to conclude the border rank of
p actually in the way back
so by knowing this rank then i want to
conclude this so well i need to compute
this run so i can manipulate this matrix
and by swapping rows and columns and
whatever and then this is equivalent
this matrix turns out to be equivalent
to this
and this is i mean this is not
this is not crazy i mean this is
somehow
it's clear it's clear right so then i
get zeros and then here i get m111
obviously right so now i know this round
because this is nine
this is
two
well think of this matrix with ones and
zeros this is going to have one two so
this rank is eleven so the total rank
is eleven
but eleven i can write it as two times
five plus one i think or five times two
plus one
so if
so five is r and
two is
three minus one
so this is not satisfied then this is
not satisfies where r is is five so i
get that the board the run is five plus
one six
so i get that
the board the rank
of p prime is
what it was yeah the projection is six
and then i just conclude by noticing
that the border rank of p is big or
equal and i'm done
so that's that's an example where where
bought their version of so i think i'm
running out of time so i just want to
mention that
it's
one can for instance produce more
examples by for instance replacing these
ones by twos
so if i do this then i just
i want to take elements in c2 tensor c2
tensor c2 then i can either choose with
both the wrong two and they want to
prove that the border rank of the sum is
7 but then an element inside there it
can be of border rank 2 it can be either
on the second the second line varieties
or on the tangential variety no doesn't
matter in both cases you do this trick
you move around these numbers and then
you get something a little bigger here
but still the rank is big enough in
order to let you conclude the same
and and this is just using this most
famous equation for probably for second
varieties but one this i was planning to
talk about but i think now my time is
over but one can also use
i'm just writing that no we also know
how to we also know one example
in the same dimension
but sticking in the same but with the
same dimensions instead of starting with
a point outside of the fourth
second variety now i take one inside
and the same for p2 and also in this so
i want a point which is on the fourth
but not on the third second variety and
in this case i'm going i'm going to use
friedland's equation because equations
for the sigma 3 of p2 tends to p2 tensor
p2 are known
but then i can also i know that the
sigma 4 of p2 tends to p2 times p2 has
to satisfy
some equations and these equations are
given by the joint matrix is like a nice
formula that involves the x1 x2 x3 so i
would do the same trick so i'm just
assuming that this proof would be by
contradiction so i assume that
the rank of the sum is
instead of six is five so it doesn't
satisfy well i mean that's that's uh
another way i mean to produce other
examples with with smaller yeah and one
can play around with the known equations
and find some more
but
i think that's
it thank you
um so what questions
i don't know but maybe some of these
techniques that can be applied uh in the
symmetrical structure conjecture that uh
was considering that
by enrico i don't know if you tried i
haven't know absolutely haven't thought
about it
yeah it could be a project
yeah
using equations for the veronese you
mean exactly
yeah i haven't yeah we haven't thought
about it
just comment
uh if you could know for instance that
there is some identifiability probably
the proof of the conjecture
you speak
yeah
i mean
if you know that there is just one
decal position probably
somehow the proof of the conjecture
would be easier of course your tensor is
not the general tensor the sense is a
block test yes
no if you can prove some that for
instance this is not a singular find of
the second variety that probably there's
some
something comes more become comes easier
to prove for
this kind of conjecture so
it could be a good idea yes to try to
see how general is your blocked answer
from that point
okay well thank you thank you again lisa